The child is 4 feet tall.
When we compare a tree it's shadow and
a child standing nearby and
the child shadow.
Because these are similar triangles,
that means that the ratio of
the height of the tree to the length
of the shadow will be proportional
to the height of the child to
the length of the child shadow.
We can set the proportion up like this.
The height of the tree over
the length of the shadow
of the tree is equivalent
to the height of the child,
which we'll set to x,
over the length of the child shadow.
When we cross multiply, we see that
20 x 10 = 50 x x, or 200 = 50x.
Divide both sides by 50 to isolate x,
and we get x is =
200/50 which is just 4.
So the child is 4 feet tall.